Messieursvbncbvcvbncvbxvb   jouer au jeu le plus perché du Youtube Games ?
Ouais mes sourcils bouge beaucoup quand je parle.
Yo tout le monde, c'est Squeezie. Ecoutez, aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
le cheveu dans le mur, un jeu qui à l'air complètement perché
Qui du coup, m'attire énormément parce qu'il est très atypique
On adore tout ce qui est atypique. Par exemple, un mec qui se pince les tétons régulièrement.
On vient d'emménager dans une nouvelle maison.
Et il y a, dans la cave, un cheveu qui sort du mur.
Ouais ouais ! Aujourd'hui, on teste un jeu comme ça, ouais !
Allez, c'est parti ! Premier jour.
Oh !
C'est quoi ces sons, là, qui stressent mon corps ?
Ahhhh...
Ca, c'est cancérigène ça hein ?
Ah mec, c'est horrible, c'est une basse en continu, putain !
Bon. "Vous venez d'emménager. Nouvelle maison. Nouveau travail. Nouvelle vie !
C'est ce que je vous avez dit, hein.
"Pendant que tu montais les étagères, tu as remarqué quelque chose au sous-sol."
"Un cheveu dans le mur."
Voilà.
Le bon poil qui dépasse du mur !
A la base, c'est arrêté, ça fait beaucoup du bien.
Si ça va mal dans ta vie, tu écoutes cette basse 30 secondes, tu l'as- tu l'arrêtes et tout va mieux !
Alors, là, il faut faire quoi avec le cheveu, il faut cliquer ? 'Faut le tirer ?
Le gameplay le plus easy !
"Tu l'as retiré. Maintenant, va dormir." OK.
"Jour 2" OK. Le jeu le plus perché de tous les temps !
"Tes voisins arrivent pour t'accueillir. Va chercher du vin."
"Peut-être y a t-il une bouteille dans le sous-sol"
Attention, est-ce que le cheveu, elle fait le le tour de la bouteille, eh ben voilà !
Eh ben voilà, on prend la bouteille, et on prend... le cheveu.
"Il est de nouveau là. Tu sais que tu en as envie. Allez vas'y. Retire-le."
Bon, vous me prenez par les sentiments. Allez-y (x4)
Non, mais honneur à vous. Appuyez, je-, je compte jusqu'à 3. 1-2 (click)
Wouah... Coopération.
"Jour 3" OK. (Rire)
C'est incroyable ce qu'on en train de vivre C'est une aventure extraordinaire.
"La dernière nuit était rugueuse. Tu n'as pas pu dormir."
C'est à cause du cheveu dans le mur, c'est ça ? Ce cheveu est hanté ?
"Pourquoi ce cheveu était encore là ? Tu est pourtant sûr de l'avoir retiré la veille."
"Actuellement, tu n'as pas le temps de penser à ça. Tu dois aller travailler et il se fait tard."
Enfin, je veux dire, il y a quand même un cheveu qui réapparaît dans le mur, enfin, c'est inquiétant.
Tu prends RTT(?) et puis tu résout ce problème. Tu brûles ta maison.
On est au travail. On est au tra- Ben, on va pouvoir faire des recherches
Quand faut faire des recherches, qui c'est qu'on appelle ?
(Insp. Squeezie) Quelqu'un requiert mon aide pour faire des recherches ?
Alors, alors, comment faire, on allume le PC, voil-
Ah hé, ce, hé je, je vais me faire la boule à zéro si ça continue.
"Vous l'avez vu, n'est-ce pas ?" (Rire) Arrête.
Eh, ça me tend, c'est quoi cette ambiance bizarre, là, putain !
Cliquez pour continuer. "Jour 4" (Rire) On se fait hanter par un cheveu, quoi !
Est-ce qu'il y a un truc plus nul pour nous hanter ? "Depuis le jour de la fête de bienvenue, tu n'es pas retourné au sous-sol." Ben, pourquoi ?
T'as peur d'un cheveu, eh, il a pas de courage, le keum ! "Et s'il était encore là ?"
Tu sais, il y a "Inside" qui te met la pression pour vraiment un truc de fou. Et il y a le cheveu dans le mur. (Rire)
"Dans ce cas, mettons fin à cette histoire une fois pour toute. Arrache-le." OK. OK. Je suis prêt, je suis prêt.
Oh ! Au couteau ! Mais si tu le tires ou ce que tu veux, c'est pareil ! Et là, mesdames, nous dirons que non. Le poil quand tu l'arrache, il met plus longtemps à repousser. Quand tu le coupes, il repousse vite et dur !
Tu te retrouves avec des jambes de yéti, eh ben mesdames, cet homme ne vous écoute pas, puisqu'il prend ce couteau.
Merde, j'ai pas eu le temps de lire.
Merde, j'ai fait une fausse manip', on va y aller au couteau. Oh !
"Ca ne marche pas. Le mur ne se casse pas. Tu as besoin d'un outil plus puissant." Ah, il veut péter le mur carrément !
Si il y a quelqu'un qui est mort dans le mur, c'est la fin de ma chaîne YouTube. (Rire) "Jour 5", arrêtez avec cette basse ! Ca m'énerve (x2) !
"Vous êtes dans un magasin de bricolage. Vous ne vous souvenez pas si vous avez dormi, mangé ou si vous êtes aller au travail."
Ou si vous avez arracher un de vos cheveux pour le mettre dans le mur. En fait, c'est nous, c'est nous putain ! "Et vous avez de moins en moins de cheveux sur la tête."
C'est tout ! Si seulement...
"Tout ce que tu sais, c'est que tu veux te débarrasser de ce cheveu dans le mur."
Oui, oui, ben oui. Sinon, sinon, on s'en bat les couilles. On le laisse à sa place, on s'en fout.
C'est un cheveu, mec ! Alors, là, mec, on va se prendre... OH, LA PERCEUSE BOSCH !
Le retour !
Perceuse Bosch, la perceuse Bosch, perceuse Bosch, perceuse Bosch (bruit de perceuse).
Elle nous hante, putain ! (Rire)
Y a la, y a la, y a le marteau-piqueur Bosch aussi.
Vas-y, on prend le truc hyper cher.
"C'était très cher. Mais ça va résoudre ton problème."
Attends, on dirait que je vais me suicider avec, avec ce truc. YAAAAAAHHHHH !
Aaaahhhh.... Oh putain. "Il y a l'air d'avoir une chambre derrière le mur." Pas le cadavre, pas le cadavre ! "Tu as besoin d'une lumière pour mieux voir."
"Ta lampe-torche sur(?) est en haut des marches." Eh ben, on va la prendre et quand on va revenir, le mur sera rela- NON ! "La vérité est proche."
Y a plus le cheveu, mais le mur, s'est reconstruit. Est-ce qu'un maçon de notre famille, parce qu'on est portugais, est passé par là ?
This is the question (C'est la question). "Il y avait un trou ici. Il n'est plus là." Merci pour cette information.
"Jour 6" (Rire) Il est horrible, c'est malsain, j'en ai marre ! "Tu as fait la meilleure nuit de TOUTE ta LIFE (VIE) !
"Le cheveu a disparu. Le trou n'a jamais été là. Tu es en sécurité maintenant. Enfin." Ouais ! Il est doué.
C'est quoi ?
What is that (Qu'est ce que c'est), what does it mean (qu'est ce que ça veut dire) ? Il faut cliquer ?
Ca se rapproche ?
Je vois un cheveu au loin.
Je vois un cheveu moins loin.
Je vois un cheveu presque proche, gravé dans la roche. Pour nos familles et nos proches, c'est.
Sniper(?) dédicace. Il est de retour. Est-ce qu'on doit cliquer ? NANI ? Ca pisse le sang.
*Jumpscare*
Ca, c'est un screamer en bois, enfin, je veux dire la meuf était vraiment en bois, c'était la meuf de Pinocchio qui nous avait fait une blague.
(Musique stressante) "Tu n'as jamais emmenagé." Non. "C'est ton ancienne maison." Non ! "Ton ancien travail" Non !! "Ton ancienne vie" NON !!!!! Et ça... c'était ta femme décédée... NON !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!! C'est la fin ?
Est-ce que c'est vraiment la fin ? C'est la fin...
C'était ça le twist de fin. (?)
Ce jeu a été fait par un enfant de 6 ans, en fait. (Rire). C'est au cours de techno que tu fais ça ! Hein, au lieu de faire le truc avec la led, là. Maintenant, tu connais un jeu d'horreur un peu moisi.
Voilà les gens, c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur le cheveu dans le mur ! N'hésitez pas à aimer si ça vous a plu ! Putain, j'étais hyper attiré par le principe du jeu, par l'image, par tout !
Et là, la chute et un peu pétée, quoi. On pouvait imaginer une chute à l'Inception ou quoi mais... pas trop !
A la très prochaine, merci d'avoir regardé ! Merci d'avoir, euh, joué à ce jeu complètement perché avec moi. L'un des plus perchés de la chaine, c'est sûr !
A très bien vite (?), portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde, PEACE !
*Musique d'outro*